millions of dollars in customer value
overnight
and for every day of the past month
the dedicated prosecutors of this office
and our partners at the FBI
SEC and cftc have been working around
the clock to figure out what happened
and to begin the process of Seeking
Justice
this morning we unsealed an eight-count
indictment charging Samuel bankman freed
ftx's founder with a series of
interrelated fraud schemes that
contributed to ftx's collapse
I authorize these charges last week
Wednesday
a grand jury here in Manhattan indicted
Mr bankman freed last week Friday
we obtained a warrant for his arrest
and that arrest was executed yesterday
in the Bahamas
now let me be clear
my remarks today are going to be limited
that is by Design
this investigation is very much ongoing
and it is moving very quickly
but I also want to be clear about
something else
while this is our first Public
Announcement it will not be our last
the indictment has eight counts but
effectively it outlines four different
areas of this conduct
first we alleged that bankman freed
defrauded customer theftx.com The
cryptocurrency Exchange he founded
second we can place a heater frauded
lender to Alameda research is
proprietary hedge fund
third wheel Leisure heat of frauded
investors in nftx
and lastly we allege that he violated
campaign Finance laws
let me say a little bit more about what
we allege in the indictment
first we charged up from 2019 until
earlier this year Bateman freed and his
co-conspirators stole billions of
dollars from FTX customers
he used that money for his personal
benefit including to make personal
Investments and to cover expenses and
debts of his hedge fund Alameda research
secondly and relatedly we charge that
bankman free lie to alameda's lenders
about the source of the money that he
was using to pay those debts
third we charged that earlier this year
in the midst of the crypto crisis
bankman freed lied to investors in FTX
about the fact that he had sent billions
of dollars in FTX customer money to
Alameda
and fourth we charged at bankman freed
violated Federal campaign Finance laws
by causing tens of millions of dollars
in a legal campaign contributions to be
made to candidates and committees
associated with both Democrats and
Republicans
these contributions were disguised to
look like they were coming from wealthy
co-conspirators when in fact the
contributions were funded by Alameda
research with stolen customer money
and all of this dirty money was used in
service of bankman Freed's desire to buy
bipartisan influence and impact the
direction of public policy in Washington
to anyone who was watching this or hears
about this prosecution if you believe
that you have been a victim of these
schemes or you have information about
the conduct that we've allege in our
indictment that we've unsealed today
please let us know
to any person entity or political
campaign that has received stolen
customer money we ask that you work with
us to return that money to the innocent
victims
and to anyone who participated in
wrongdoing at FTX or Alameda research
and who has not yet come forward
I would strongly encourage you to come
see us before we come see you
now let me say a word about our partners
at the FBI the SEC and the cftc
the women and men of the FBI are some of
the finest public servants in this
country and they have been with us since
day one in this investigation and there
is no one no one better to work with
I want to thank the brilliant lawyers at
the SEC and the cftc
this investigation is complex and it's
sprawling
we Embrace that kind of challenge here
in the southern district of New York
and we always want the cftc and the SEC
by our side when we're doing that
and finally I want to thank the career
prosecutors from my office handling this
case
Nicholas Rose and Danielle Sassoon and
their supervisors Scott Hartman and
Matthew Podolski the chiefs of our
Securities and commodities fraud task
force
I want to acknowledge the contributions
and hard work of the prosecutors from
our money laundering and transnational
criminal Enterprises unit including
Samuel Raymond and Thane Wren and their
Chiefs Jessica Feinstein and Tara
lamorte
and I want to acknowledge the
contributions from the chief of our
public corruption unit Rebecca donoleski
this should be very clear but it's an
all hands on deck investigation here in
sdny and I couldn't be prouder of the
team that I'm privileged to lead
I now want to invite up to the podium
FBI assistant director in charge Michael
Driscoll
thank you Damien
so thank you all for joining us this
afternoon for this important
announcement
this case came together at great speed
and such that it's only possible to be
standing here today through tremendous
coordination and cooperation for many
people and agencies
as the indictment today alleges bankman
freed knowingly defrauded customers of
FTX through the misappropriation of
customer deposits to pay expenses and
debts of a different company
in addition bankman freed executed
deliberate transactions designed to
obscure and disguise
the misuse of customer funds
he preyed on his customers the victims
of this case abusing the trust placed
not only in his company but in himself
as the lead of that company
we are determined to help the victims of
this case get a sense of justice and we
will continue to make every attempt to
recover as much of their funds as
possible
if you're willing to deceive customers
and attempt to hide your actions we will
be persistent in pursuing you and
ensuring you are brought to Justice I
want to thank Damien Williams and his
team at the southern district for their
cooperation and partnership on this case
I also want to thank our partners at the
SEC and the cftc for their outstanding
work a word of thanks to dea's Aviation
division their foreign operations group
for their Logistics and Resource
Assistance over the past few days
our field offices in Boston Miami
Washington DC and our league at office
in Bridgetown
FBI headquarters components that fed and
worked on this case from Criminal
investigative division our third team
crisis incident Response Group and our
International Operations Division
and of course the Special Agents from
and forensic accountants from our
Securities fraud Squad as well as the
money laundering Squad
the justice department office of
international Affairs has been an
important partner in this and of course
as Damian noted before his team and
securities and commodities fraud
money laundering and transnational
criminal Enterprise unit has been a true
partner in this case
I also want to thank our international
law enforcement Partners these kind of
cases do not have happen without that
kind of coordination and I specifically
want to note the assistance provided by
the Royal Bahamas police force
and I want to be clear
this case is about fraud fraud is fraud
it does not matter the complexity of the
investment scheme it does not matter the
amount of money involved
if you mislead and deceive to take what
does not belong to you we will hold you
accountable
and I'd like to thank everyone who's
been working on this case
for helping us adhere to that principle
today thank you
good afternoon everyone I'm Kabir Grewal
the director of the sec's division of
enforcement
today in a parallel civil complaint the
SEC filed charges against Sam bankman
freed alleging that he orchestrated a
years-long scheme to defraud Equity
investors in FTX trading limited a
company that he co-founded and led as
CEO until its collapse last month
as alleged in our complaint starting in
2019 and continuing through November
2022 bankman freed raised more than 1.8
billion dollars from Equity investors on
the basis of Lies you see FTX operated
behind a veneer of legitimacy that
bankman freed created by among other
things repeatedly touting to investors
ftx's top-notch automated risk controls
that he claimed protect protected
customer assets and by repeatedly
claiming that those assets
for at all times safe segregated and
secure
but as we allege in our complaint that
veneer wasn't just thin
it was also fraudulent because in
reality from ftx's inception in 2019
bankman freed began secretly and
improperly diverting FTX customer funds
to his crypto hedge fund Alameda
research
and as a legend our complaint he then
misused those funds to make undisclosed
Venture Investments lavish real estate
purchases and large political donations
bankman Freed's claims about ftx's
sophisticated risk controls and other
customer protections were simply bogus
similarly his representations to FTX
investors and trading customers
concerning Alameda were also part of
that carefully crafted veneer and were
similarly false and misleading
he frequently claimed that Alameda was
just another customer with no special
privileges at FTX
but in truth bankman free directed that
Alameda be exempt from the very risk
management measures that he touted to
FTX investors and to its customers
he also provided Alameda a virtually
unlimited line of credit funded by FTX
customers
and he also diverted billions of dollars
in customer funds from FTX to Alameda
bankman Freed's entire house of cards
started to crumble as crypto asset
prices plummeted in May of 2022
and as alameda's lenders demanded
repayment on billions of dollars in
loans
but to continue propping up his Empire
we allege that bank been freed diverted
billions more in FTX customer assets to
Alameda even as it was increasingly
clear that Alameda and FTX could not
make those customers whole
in fact through the summer of 2022 he
deferred he diverted hundreds of
millions more in FTX customer funds to
Alameda which he then used for
additional Venture Investments and for
loans to himself and to other FTX
executives
all the while he continued to make
misleading statements to investors about
ftx's financial condition and about its
risk management
and even in November 2022 faced with
billions of dollars in customer
withdrawal requests that FTX could not
fulfill
bankman freed misled investors from whom
he sought still more money to plug the
multi-billion dollar holes that he had
created
his Brazen multi-year scheme finally
came to an end when FTX Alameda and
their tangled web of Affiliates filed
for bankruptcy on November 11 2022.
that collapse has had far-reaching
consequences for FTX customers for its
investors and for its counterparties
and our investigation into those
consequences and to those individuals
and entities involved remains ongoing
but one immediate takeaway from today's
announcement should be that
non-compliant trading platforms pose
dramatic risks to both their investors
and to their customers
among other things they don't provide
them with the same robust level of
disclosures and protections against
fraud and conflicts of interest
that's what traditional U.S registered
Securities exchanges provide
so it's imperative that non-compliant
platforms come into compliance
but as chair gamzler has made clear the
runway is getting shorter for them to
come in and to register with us and for
those who do not the enforcement
division stands ready to take action
I'd like to recognize the incredible
team from our crypto assets and cyber
unit and from across our division
responsible for today's action
devil and Sue Ivan Snyder David Brown
Brian huckrow Pasha salimi investigated
this matter under the supervision of Amy
Hartman Michael Brennan Jorge tenrero
and David Hirsch Amy Burkhart and David
dottio will lead the will lead the
litigation against bankman freed under
the supervision of ladan Stewart and
Olivia Chet finally I want to commend
our partners here at the southern
district of New York under the
leadership of U.S attorney Damian
Williams and our partners at the FBI and
the cftc this is a yet another strong
example of the collaboration that you
see before you this afternoon with that
I'll turn it back to U.S attorney
Williams thank you
I'd like to welcome up Gretchen Lowe
from the cftc
good afternoon I'm acting director
production of acting director of the
division of forcement at the cfdc
Gretchen Lowe thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak speak today
today the cftc filed a complaint against
Sam Benton freed and his company's FTX
and Alameda charging a fraudulent scheme
that dates back to the launch of
ftx.com Exchange in May 2019 the cftc's
complaint specifically charges
defendants with fraud by
misappropriation of customer funds as
well as false statements to the public
customers investors in Congress about
the handling and security of those funds
as alleged there are over 8 billion in
customer losses that we've ascertained
as of today the Rippling consequences of
defendants fraud are vast and have done
significant damage to the Integrity of
the evolving digital asset Market
the cfdc charges that at bankman Freed's
Direction FTX customers customer
deposits intended to be used to trade
digital asset commodity Futures swaps
and other pro products were not
appropriately segregated by FTX instead
customer funds were held in Alameda
accounts where they were co-mingled and
misappropriated for a variety of
unauthorized purposes such as use in
high-risk Investments and other digital
asset Enterprises political
contributions and to purchase luxury
real estate
as charged the fraudulent use of
customer funds by banking freed and his
companies were inconsistent with the
touted FTX terms of service and contrary
to numerous statements made by public
statements made by bankman freed the
cfdc also charges the defendants created
features in the underlying code for FTX
that allowed Alameda to have essentially
an unlimited line of credit on the
exchange
defendants also provided Alameda with
unfair trading advantages including
quicker execution times and the
exemption from ftx's Auto Liquidation
risk management process
this massive and costly fraud was in the
connection with commodities interstate
commerce and as allege including Bitcoin
ether and tether which are the most
widely traded digital Assets in the
world
Bitcoin and ether also underlie
derivatives contracts on cftc designated
exchanges
lastly standing here today with the U.S
attorney's office at the southern
district FBI and the SEC
represents yet another Stellar example
of the importance of federal regulators
and Federal Criminal authorities working
collaboratively and effectively with
each other to achieve Justice the teams
work quickly and tirelessly to obtain
compelling evidence and to begin to hold
those responsible for the FTX collapse
accountable
all within a very short time frame thank
you to all at the sdny FBI and SEC for
your cooperation
and thank you to the cftc team Nina
rubinski Carlin Metzger Brian Sue Ben
Jackman Yousef Japan supervised by
deputy director Robert Howell and chief
trial Elizabeth Pendleton and many many
others at the commission who supported
the work
I am proud of your your hard work your
dedication to the mission of the
commission and for always acting in the
public interest thank you
all right happy to take some questions
number one
um what is the situation with
extradition and finally
um he didn't fit the profile of someone
who you would think would be behind this
I don't know what the profile is
typically but he wore shorts and a
t-shirt he was incredibly bright can you
addressed the fact that he didn't fit
the profile in that part of the way he
was able to fool so many people well you
can commit fraud and shorts and t-shirts
in the sun I mean that's possible too
um so I think that that addresses the
the last question in terms of whether
we're going to bring charges against
anyone else
um look I can only say it this clearly
but we are not done
extradition is ongoing in the Bahamas I
don't have anything to add on that next
question
okay so on the on the the timing of the
arrests as I mentioned before I
authorized charges last week Wednesday
and he was indicted as a defendant in
this District as of last week Friday and
we had a warrant for his arrest and so
the timing um was dictated by law
enforcement as opposed to any other
considerations
um including the timing of his testimony
in Congress he was wanted for arrest and
we and we acted on that in terms of the
speed of the of the investigation you're
right this is very very fast but I've
also underscored that we're not done
um but we have a track record here I
think you've seen us you know this group
in particular
at this Podium multiple times since I've
been U.S attorney announcing charges in
this space with with a lot of speed
um I think that's a result of the
collaboration and the hard work and the
determination to make sure that we are
acting as soon as possible and no sooner
next question
foreign
look I think today's announcement is
about one person
um and and his conduct
um it is fair to say that
um this office and our partners were
standing with us today are very very
active in this space I can't say
anything more than that
next question
so if you're asking about who is
cooperating who is not cooperating with
our investigation I'm not at Liberty to
say who has come in I will reiterate the
call that I made before that if you have
not reached out to us to talk to us I
would encourage you strongly to do so
and do so quickly
next question
is
I think in you know all of the the
department
well I'll take the last question first I
mean I don't think it's fair for me to
speculate as to what could have been
done differently by whom and when
um to prevent something like this from
happening I mean we've alleged willful
misconduct and fraud and so ultimately
from where I sit given my role I view
the fault as being with the people who
we have
alleged either in
um you know the indictment or you know
references CC's co-conspirators as being
the people who are responsible for for
this happening
um can you repeat the first question
again yeah
first person
I'm not going to expand beyond what I've
said previously next question
um
okay so that's a lot of questions
um
look I'm not going to get ahead of
ourselves in terms of what we may or may
not seek when he is here he's currently
in the Bahamas and I'm not going to
interfere with that that process by
making a comment at this point in time
in terms of the contributions that we've
discussed today and in the indictment
um uh you know I'm not going to be able
to expand upon who knew what um we have
alleged what we have alleged and if we
have more to add at any point we will we
will do so then
it's so hard to compare these things but
I think it's fair to say that by any
anyone's likes this is one of the
biggest Financial frauds in American
history
any other questions
okay thank you everybody